c'est au château de pinceloup as ton
chant que se prépare un événement bien
particulier mêlant poésie et nature
soutenu par le parc régional de la
vallée de chevreuse le projet trait
d'union propose une collaboration entre
artistes poètes de la maison triolet
aragon et jeunes élèves de la fondation
le nôtre par le biais d'ateliers poésie
la maison triolet aragon intervient-elle
au château de pinceau et sur trois jours
pour proposer des ateliers autour de la
poésie avec l'idée de créer une bande
sonore dont qui mènerait à la fois des
sons que les élèves de l'école lenôtre
ou kia s'est beaucoup dans les murs du
château de pinces ou va aller capter
dans le parquet les différents espaces
dans lesquels ils travaillent ils seront
ensuite assemblés à la voix de ces mêmes
élèves récitant des textes donc aux
différents poèmes de différentes époques
qui tous sont liés par une même
thématique d'une part il ya un premier
travail de défrichage qui est fait pour
favoriser la compréhension puisque les
élèves auprès desquels nous intervenons
sont pas francophones
c'est mon plus jeune âge j'ai rappelé à
savoir plus
ça fait un an je sais enfin un travail
difficile mélangeant littérature et
environnement que ces étudiants en
horticulture aborde avec un grand
enthousiasme
j'en ai six ont plusieurs projets du
coup en cours tout cette année ils
étaient en classe préparatoire
ils ont donc beaucoup travaillé dans la
serre qui se trouve là juste à côté ils
ont fait beaucoup de bouturage de ce
miseront a pris avec leurs éducateurs
les différentes techniques valeur permet
à la fois donc d'être dans une position
de d'apprenants mais aussi l'être
vraiment acteur dans la mesure où par
exemple la prise de son en extérieur
leur permet de montrer leur travail les
lieux qu'ils fréquentent pas ça a été
plutôt positif les jeunes se sont
montrés motivés plus tôt investi
certains jeunes ont mémorisé leurs
poèmes ce que je ne pensais pas au
départ c'est des poèmes qui sont quand
même pour beaucoup assez compliquée du
victor hugo du rimbaud etc mais ils se
sont intéressés au projet un projet fait
avec le coeur mélangeant installations
graphique et sonore qui prendra place le
8 octobre gratuitement dans les couloirs
du château